so now that we've done at the fine stage
we're moving on to the diverse stage
right the diverse stage is the next one
the diverse stage is a chance for
everyone to be thinking with their own
creativity and imagination how should
this problem be solved
you said solution so you mean more than
one right yeah we starting to think
about solutions not just one everybody's
thinking about many solutions and then
the team is how is thinking about hole
source solutions and that makes the team
powerful everyone has time individually
to work on some solutions and as they
are ready with this then they share it
with the team and suddenly they're
looking a whole dessert tray of options
for what the product could be it is so
exciting one thing that's really excited
about the stage is how quickly it can
happen we do not exercise that familiar
to some people from gamestorming it is
called
the Crazy Eights okay how does that go
the crazy no well here it goes the Crazy
eight gives everyone a little piece of
paper and they ask the the team to
sketch eight ideas in five minutes
usually the first reaction that people
have when you ask them to sketch eight
years in five minutes is they think
you're crazy and that's why we call it
the Crazy Eights
as soon as they answered this question
they look at the face of the leader and
when they fingers it is actually serious
then they returned to the writing and
they start sketching in five minutes
people were able to do five six seven
sometimes eight ideas that allows them
to warm up the mind the creative muscles
are starting to flex it's kind of like a
warm-up for a workout after that we give
the team another piece of paper and
another five minutes and we say from the
ideas that you already have can you give
me one big sketch label it clearly and
explain what are the pieces of this
layout that you're creating some people
might be intimidated by the sketching
process this is when we remind them that
we are asking them to sketch simple
things a grid that's based of rectangles
some text labels some some placeholders
for pictures and anti-culture
with that reminder most people are ready
to reimagine themselves is the is the
creative child that they once were